كان هذا الناطق باسم الدفاع المدني في غزه
محمود
بصل هذا وكان المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه رائد النمس قال ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يستهدف اي جسم متحرك
في محيط مستشفى الامل في خان يونس ويتعمد
التشويش على الموجات اللاسلكيه التي
تستخدمها طواقم
الاغاثه
في الواقع منذ ليله امس والطيران
الاسرائيلي يكثف غاراته في محيط مستشفى
الامل وفي يعني مجمل غرب خانيونس بشكل عام
عبر احزمه ناريه طوقت المستشفى وطبعا هذا
هذه الاعتداءات ليست بجديده فهو منذ اكثر
من ثلاثه اسابيع يستهدف محيط مستشفى الامل
التابع للجم ومقر الجمعيه ايضا بخان يونس
بهدف اخراجها عن الخدمه واجبار جميع
النازحين المتوجين في مقر الجمعيه بخان
يونس والذي يفوق عددهم ال 133000 نازح
واجبارهم على التحرك الى محافظه رفح ضمن
سياسه تهجير قصريه تبع الاحتلال منذ بدء
العدوان كما تعلمون نجد صعوبه بالغه في
التواصل مع الكوادر العامله سواء كانت
الاسعافيه او الصحيه او حتى في غرفه
العمليات المتواجده الان في خانيونس والتي
يتعمد جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التشويش
على الموجات الاسلكيه التي نتعامل بها عبر
التواصل النا العامله ناهيك عن يعني
الاستهداف المباشر لاي جسم متحرك في هذه
في محيط هذه المنطقه والتي يعني بات هناك
يعني عدد شهداء كبير على مدار الايام
الماضيه جراء الاستهدافات المتعمده لمقر
الجمعيه في خس نحن الان يعني يعتبر هذا
تحدي جديد واختراق جديد لمبادئ القانون
الدولي
الانساني